bye
today these men soldiers of a free
country
are leaving to fight today our
battlefield is the world
our transports our freighters go to the
furthest
islands of the earth
men of the united nations are landing
everywhere
soldiers from new york and chicago are
moving up to fight in the empty desert
to fight on battlefields of snow
and in the jungle men from the little
towns of montana
moving up in the heat of asia africa the
caribbean
their job is fighting they must be kept
safe
against disease against the special
dangers of the jungle
behind our men stand scientists of the
western hemisphere
these doctors are good neighbors from
two american countries
the united states and the republic of
colombia
here were their first battles their
weapons the test tube
the sterilized needle between the
equator and the panama canal
they fought their silent war their enemy
was hidden in the green branches of the
jungle
here the heat of the sky pours down 12
hours a day
there is no autumn no spring only months
of heat
and months of rain life is quick and
abundant and death is also abundant
here was the home of jungle yellow fever
a man who came here to work
or to fight on these dark trails was
condemned to grow sick
delirious eyes and skin turning yellow
before he died
a disease of young men of those who
built a house
or a camp in the infected forest
death waited for them in the heat of the
valleys wooden crosses for the young men
who dared to walk in the jungle
they died from the bite of a mosquito
in a few laboratories they put this
disease behind glass and studied it
it was a virus it had to be fed on
living tissue
on unborn chicks and human blood serum
it was dangerous invisible had killed
men who worked with it
what they needed was a vaccine to
prevent yellow fever
and the fight never stopped till it was
found till it was tested
purified till it could be dried and
frozen
and prepared in quantity until it could
be transported
the first battle had been won inside the
white walls of a laboratory
the second battle was here in the heat
and wet of the jungle
above their heads was the solution to
the mystery of jungle yellow fever
the guilty mosquitoes lived and bred not
in pools on the ground
but in the treetops
they bit not only men but animals
especially monkeys
and thousands of monkeys grew sick but
did not die
their blood was a living reservoir of
yellow fever
mosquitoes which had fed on these
monkeys flew down from the treetops
attacked men and infected them with a
virus of yellow fever
to ride on these trails became a
sentence of death
but carried in this thermos jug too
precious to go on mule back
are tubes of vaccine packed in ice
moving over narrow trails and slippery
bridges
in a jungle area without railroads
without highways
across rivers too steep for navigation
at night they set up their portable
refrigerator unit
to renew the supply of ice in the
morning
it is carried on mule back with the
needles and syringes
a task force against yellow fever
there's a gray hot sunday in the town of
copair
there's market day too and there is good
news
yes it is true the doctors are coming
sunday mass is just over and in front of
the church
the news spreads it is true it is
printed
it is signed by the mayor the priest
himself has given his blessing
it has come at last
now the slow pack train climbs up the
hill from the jungle
the doctors have come to the town of
gopher
the every amarilla the yellow fever
the fever that eats men that kills their
fathers
their brothers the fever of the jungle
is to be
feared no longer the blessed medicine
has come
years of difficult work years of
collaboration between men of the united
states
cuba panama brazil colombia years of
courage in the laboratory and in the
jungle
come to their climax here in this patio
of the mayor's house
the vaccination will be here in the open
air
it is a dull cloudy afternoon 200 miles
north of the equator
the vaccine is removed from the thermos
jug
the instruments are sterilized in
boiling water
there are people here who read slowly
others who have never learned
but there's one word they know nacion
vaccination that word means life
and they know one thing more that if
three are sick with yellow fever
two will surely die and only one will
live
the names of the people are written down
the harness maker's wife
a farmer and his son
a woman is the first to be vaccinated
and now two more
these are a mixed people descendants of
indians
and of the spanish conquerors
a few drops of vaccine injected under
the skin of the arm
will give them dependable and lasting
immunity
those whose names are in this book need
have no fear of yellow fever
there is only one shock there is no
illness afterwards
the protection lasts for years perhaps
for life
it is a product of the genius of the
combined americas
already 500 000 citizens of colombia
have been vaccinated
now the vaccine is taken to army
hospitals where the entire colombian
army
unit by unit is vaccinated against
yellow fever
now they can go safely to their outposts
in the jungle
these soldiers are safe and because of
this pioneering work
when our heavy guns are lifted in the
jungle the men behind them will be
strong
ready to fight in the african congo on
the dark islands of the south pacific
in the jungles of burma and the solomons
in the depths of new guinea
and the philippines when we come to take
them one by one
our men today are safe against yellow
fever
free to fight the worst disease of all
fascism until that too shall be blasted
from the face of the earth
you